pour en parler on reçoit le ministre du
Travail du Québec jean-boulé bonsoir
Monsieur boulet bonsoir madame
Saint-Arnaud alors vous avez pris
connaissance des recommandations du
Comité consultatif elle devrait
d'ailleurs être rendue publique
prochainement les grands constats c'est
quoi
les grands consistants vous l'avez
mentionné c'est un ange minimum de 14
ans en bas de 14 ans il y aura des
exceptions ce qui est surtout important
c'est que à 11-12 ans il faut que le
travail soit proportionné aux capacités
de l'enfant et ne compromettent pas son
éducation et ne nuisent pas à sa santé
sécurité intégrité physique ou psychique
et pour
l'enfant ou l'étudiant qui doit
fréquenter l'école jusqu'à 16 ans il y
aurait un maximum de 17 ans par semaine
évidemment on exclut les périodes de
relâche et de vacances estivales et
pendant les journées les cinq journées
de la semaine où le jeûne doit être à
l'école ce serait limité à 10h entre le
lundi matin à 6h et le vendredi à 23h
donc c'est limite là et ça rendra la
législation québécoise beaucoup plus
compatible avec le reste du Canada et
les conventions internationales et le
but madame Saint-Arnaud c'est vraiment
mieux encadrer le travail des enfants
pour assurer une meilleure réussite
éducative et protéger leur santé et
sécurité est-ce qu'ils sont protégés au
même titre que les autres travailleurs
en ce moment avec les règles en vigueur
monsieur boulet dans la Loi sur les
normes du travail ça prend un
consentement des parents en bas de 14
ans dans la loi santé sécurité tout
employeur et indépendamment de l'ange du
travailleur doit
identifier les risques à la santé
sécurité tenter de les contrôler et de
les éliminer évidemment on les éliminera
pas totalement mais oui les enfants sont
quand même protégés et peuvent faire une
réclamation à la cnsst pour être
indemnisé c'est d'ailleurs ce qui nous a
alerté on est en contexte de pénurie de
main d'oeuvre il y a de plus en plus
d'enfants de 10 11 12 ans qui
travaillent et le nombre de réclamations
pour accident de travail est en
augmentation considérable et on se doit
d'intervenir pour mieux encadrer et
reconfirmer que ces véritablement une
responsabilité partagée entre les
parents et les employeurs et aussi les
jeunes de se protéger vous dites
monsieur boulet il y en a de plus en
plus évidemment on l'a observé dans les
derniers mois on a l'impression que les
employés de certains commerces ou de
certains secteurs sont de plus en plus
jeunes mais ce qu'on a une idée précise
combien il y en a dans quel secteur
travaillent-ils est-ce qu'on a des
données là-dessus on n'a pas de portrait
statistiques précis c'est d'ailleurs une
des recommandations des associations
patronales et syndicales qu'on documente
mieux et qu'on est une idée beaucoup
plus précise du nombre d'enfants par
certains d'activités et par emploi une
étude sur la population active que vous
connaissez qui provient de Statistiques
Canada où on a le nom de jeunes entre 15
et 19 ans mais en bas de 15 ans c'est
actuellement pas documenté de façon
totalement
exhaustive avec la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre monsieur boulet évidemment
c'est une main d'oeuvre où il y en a des
candidats disponibles il y a des
employeurs qui disent de ne plus avoir
le choix que de se tourner vers ces
jeunes là 11 12 13 ans qu'est-ce que
vous leur répondez ben je leur réponds
que ce qui est important c'est de
d'assurer un environnement de travail
qui soit sain et sécurité et d'éviter
les risques comme le travail répétitif
sur une période de temps prolongée
l'exposition à des contaminants ou des
activités qui sont
incompatibles avec les capacités de
l'enfant ou qui nuisent à son
développement il faut éviter ça moi ça
m'apparaît fondamental il faut encore
une fois revenir à l'importance du rôle
des parents dans cette situation là
justement il le concept d'une
responsabilité partagée entre employeurs
et les parents est-ce que est-ce qu'il y
a pas des risques d'abus est-ce qu'il y
aura d'ailleurs des sanctions pour les
employeurs qui respectent pas le maximum
de 17 heures par exemple c'est
intéressant ce que vous mentionnez parce
que l'été dernier on a fait une escouade
prévention à la cnssi il y a des
inspecteurs qui sont allés dans les
secteurs notamment commerce de détails
hébergement restaurant où il y a plus
d'enfants pour faire des ateliers de
formation sensibiliser informer puis
former et évidemment dans toute loi
quand une personne respecte pas ou abuse
il pourrait y avoir des constats
d'infraction et pourrait y avoir des
amendes qui sont imposées faut d'abord
faire de la pédagogie avant d'imposer
des pénalités mais il faut y aller de
façon graduelle il faut développer au
Québec une culture de respect de la
capacité des enfants dans tous les
milieux de travail puis ça prend la
collaboration tout le monde et c'est la
raison pour laquelle on a eu un au
comité consultatif les patrons les
syndicats et je vous rappellerai qu'il y
a eu consultation de la Commission des
droits de la personne et des droits de
la jeunesse lors des conseillers
ressources humaines agréés du Québec la
Commission de la cnsst ou aussi et ces
gros plats de même que le réseau
québécois pour la réussite éducative ce
qui est important c'est l'école et la
santé des enfants le projet de loi en
février monsieur boulet c'est mon
intention évidemment c'est un avis qui a
été qui m'a été remis par le comité
consultatif on va continuer de
l'analyser faire des consultations
additionnelles et mon objectif c'est de
déposer un projet de loi au début de la
prochaine session parlementaire très
bien on va suivre ça de près j'en
voulais ministre du Travail merci
beaucoup d'avoir été là merci à bientôt
madame Saint-Arnaud au revoir pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI